bonsoir à tous je m'appelle loubna alors
on se connaît pas encore mais je me
permets de vous poser une question un
peu personnel vous sentez vous à votre
place vous sentez vous
vraiment à votre place prenez quelques
secondes pour y réfléchir
ces deux dernières années j'ai vu des
femmes prendre leur place dans la
société et voir leur vie basculer en
seulement deux ans alors je suis pas
coach de développement personnel mais je
suis entrepreneur et avec mes amis
dounia et youssef nous avons créé meet
my mama avec un rêve celui de redonner à
des femmes des femmes trop souvent
inaudible ou invisible de redonner à ces
femmes leur place dans la société
ces femmes on les appelle nos mamans
elles sont merveilleuses et elle cuisine
comme personne elle cuisine même encore
mieux de série mars pas où vous êtes
je fais souvent cette phrase mais c'est
la première fois devant thierry chum
self mais c'est pour vous faire prendre
conscience que ces femmes elles ont ce
talent si on a envie de manger le
meilleur tajine aux vaches et une mama
n'est ce pas elles ont de l'or entre les
mains et elles ont de l'or dans le coeur
on connaît tous une mama qui cuisine
super bien et si vous creusez un peu
très souvent elles ont ce rêve se rêve
de pouvoir vivre de leur passion pour la
cuisine ouvrir un restaurant un traiteur
peu importe tout ce qu'elle veut c'est
vous partager leurs plans mais très
souvent ce rêve demeure brisé pour
plusieurs raisons plusieurs freins la
barrière de la langue le manque de
confiance en soi le manque de réseaux de
moyens le fait d'être une femme aussi
dans un domaine où plus de 90% des chefs
sont des hommes tous ces freins fonds
qu'elle ne se lance jamais et nous ça
nous a frustrés
alors on a créé un programme d'emploi
hormones en trois étapes la première
inspired my mama pour leur donner des
déclics la deuxième la mama académie
pour les former la troisième need my
mama pour transformer leur talent en
opportunités économiques
maintenant sur la plateforme elles
peuvent proposer leurs services à des
milliers d'entreprises
on a pu rencontrer donc une cinquantaine
de femmes qui viennent de pays
différents qui ont des âges différents
qui ont des parcours très différents
femme au foyer femmes battues aux femmes
en situation d'isolement femmes
diplômées femmes en reconversion
professionnelle bref des parcours très
différents mais qui sont reliés par une
passion la cuisine
ces femmes aujourd'hui je suis hyper ému
de vous annoncer qu'elles ont réussi ces
femmes aujourd'hui elle son chef
indépendante et entrepreneurs et elles
ont trouvé leur place
à travers ce talk je vais vous devez
vous expliquer comment elles ont fait à
travers cinq petites histoires cinq
éléments qui j'espère vont vous aider
vous aussi à trouver votre place
la première histoire c'est celle de mama
sarah sahara c'est un talent qui a été
qui a été enfoui pendant des années dans
un petit appartement dans lieux
parisienne sarah pendant 20 ans elle a à
la cuisine et pour sa famille
des plats tous les plus incroyables les
uns que les autres imaginez ou plutôt
compter 20 ans trois fois par jour cela
fait plus de 21 mille neuf cents repas
cuisinés n'allez surtout pas dire
qu'elle n'a pas d'expérience mais pour
soraya c'était normal c'était son rôle
et la cuisine dans son pays c'est une
institution l adorer ça elle se révèle
être chef
mais ce talent été censuré par un mari
violent
c'est avec son dû
un divorce où elle a tout perdu son
logement son travail son mari c'est
grâce à ça qu'elle a qu'elle s'est vue
revivre puisque soria est un phénix un
phénix avec une étoile son fils son fils
qu'un jour nous a écrit avec comme objet
du mail please make my mama
alors il nous a invités on est arrivé on
ne savait pas trop à quoi s'attendre et
la sara débarque avec un tajine
merveilleux je m'en souviens encore la
viande et et fondante l'assaisonnement
était parfait l'assiette était joliment
dressées bref on venait de tomber sur
une perle
et c'est là que l'histoire commence
c'est d'abord avec un peu de timidité
que sera sarah dévoile son talent au
grand public mais très vite sous les
applaudissements les regards admirateurs
sont à sarah prend confiance en elle
sarah prend sa place et elle est là sa
place à l'est parmi les chefs
aujourd'hui sarah elle cuisine au grand
palais al cuisine avec les plus grands
elle est même demandé à l'international
après vingt ans de cauchemar
c'est grâce à son talent son talent
qu'elle a pu trouver sa place
la deuxième histoire c'est celle de
harati parmi nos mamans certaines était
comptable d'autres étaient cadres mais
elle ne se sentait pas à leur place
c'est peut-être votre cas aujourd'hui où
c'est peut-être le cas de quelqu'un de
votre entourage vous savez cette
personne qui a réussi des études
brillantes elles étaient sur moi d'ofi
cette personne qui a un job de rêve mais
qui au fond d'elle même elle sans qu il
lui manque quelque chose
cette personne est dans ce qu'on appelle
la sueur adaptation c'est le fait de
vouloir rentrer dans le moule de ce que
l'on pense que les gens attendent de
nous bien souvent cette personne a là
une petite flamme une petite flamme qui
la chatouille au travail
une flamme qui l'empêchent de dormir
vous savez cette idée qu'on a en tête et
qui nous quitte plus bas à réty elle
avait cette idée cette idée de lancer
son restaurant elle l'a fait vous direz
c'est plus facile à dire qu'à faire
et c'est vrai elle s'est battue elle a
rencontré tous les freins possibles par
manque de confiance
par exemple aucune banque lui a permis
d'avoir un crédit à l'aide juste se
former elle qu'il est déjà mère de deux
enfants elle a dû aussi faire face à
l'incompréhension l'incompréhension de
ses proches
imaginez l'incompréhension des gens qui
vous aiment au final c'est comme si vous
débarquez un jour devant vos parents et
vous leur dites après vos études à
dauphine
je veux être cuisinier malgré tous ces
freins harati n'a pas baissé les bras
elle est battante et les opportunités
qu'on n'allait pas lui donner l aller
les prendre
alors elle a commencé à faire les
marchés et même l'hiver même sous la
pluie
chaque vente chaque minute constituait
pour elle un apprentissage et un premier
capital pour atteindre son rêve
je l'admiré
beaucoup à radio aujourd'hui elle est
chef d'entreprise et quand on l'a
rencontré on l'aide
on l'a aidé justement a créé cette
entreprise traiteur aujourd'hui à les
chèvres connues et à la cuisine et pour
plus de deux cents 200 événements meet
my mama tous nos clients ce larache les
ministères google lvmh
bref elle a réussi et vous savez quoi
elle a réussi à ouvrir son restaurant
mais mieux que ça
son restaurant a été classée parmi les
trois meilleurs concepts de paris par
l'académie nationale de cuisine elle a
de quoi être fier mais sa plus grande
fierté c'est d'avoir conquis conquis la
fierté de ses parents son père lui a dit
pour la première fois je suis fier de
toi elle son mari l'a même rejoint dans
son concept
voilà ce que ça fait que de tout quitter
pour vivre de sa passion
certes c'est dur ça demande beaucoup
d'endurance mais au final ça vaut le
coup et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui à ratier a le sourire le
sourire d'une personne qui a retrouvé sa
place
krishna reyssouze l'adorent elle est
attachante
quand on l'a rencontré elle venait
d'arriver en france
réfugié on l'a placé dans un appartement
avec d'autres familles qu'elle ne
connaissait pas pas de logement à elle
pas de travail même les banques les
banques l'ont refusé d'ouvrir son compte
en banque
bref comment trouver sa place dans ces
conditions vous commencez à me connaître
j'aime les petites anecdotes alors pour
celles ci je vais prendre le tout
premier événement de meet my mama est le
tout premier événement de mama krishna
je me souviens comme si c'était hier on
lui avait passé les clés d'un restaurant
pour qu'elle puisse réaliser son rêve
être la star la chef d'un soir
elle nous a préparé un plein merveilleux
et même mieux
une expérience on avait l'impression
d'être en malaisie c'était génial et
elle était vraiment devenu une star à
travers cet événement elle a adoré ce
sentiment et vous savez ce cas nous a
dit à la fin de l'événement
elle nous a même pas remercier elle nous
a dit s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
envoyez moi toutes les photos l'art
maintenant j'ai trouvé ça bizarre au
début mais j'ai compris j'ai compris
puisqu'elle m'a expliqué qu'elle avait
fermé son compte facebook pendant deux
ans pourquoi parce qu'elle ne voulait
pas montrer à ses proches
la situation dans les qualités mais
grâce à ça
elle allait retrouver sa vie et c'est ce
qui s'est passé au fur et à mesure des
prestations avec meet manama au fur et à
mesure de l'argent gagné
elle a pu avoir un logement décent faire
ramener son mari et sa mère en france et
à la pub et yes des études aux meilleurs
conservatoires de paris à sa fille vous
voyez où je veux en venir
l'argent et le travail pour une femme
c'est important ça permet vraiment de
s'insérer dans la société aujourd'hui
son mari la voix autrement ses enfants
la voient autrement et la société la
considère autrement et ça l a bien
compris écrit fier et aujourd'hui son
conseil pour vous c'est money money
money comme elle le fait si bien
money money money ait atteint
comment trouver sa place dans un pays où
sa propre culture n'est pas comprise
voir acceptées l'afghanistan l'iran la
roumanie quand on vient de ces pays
on a du mal à trouver sa place les
préjugés les inquiétudes nous font
prendre nous font comprendre que nous ne
sommes pas ici chez nous et très souvent
dans ces cas-là ce qui se passe c'est
qu'on essaye de copié l'autre pour
s'intégrer
on est un peu un peu sa culture pour la
remplacer par celle de l'autre c'est ce
qu'on appelle le syndrome de zellige
comme le film éponyme de woody allen où
son personnage pour se faire aimer se
fond complètement dans le décor alors ça
fonctionne à temps mais je peux vous le
dire qu'au fond de soi au bout d'un
moment on sent qu'on n'est pas
totalement nous mêmes c'est arrivé à
certaines de nos mamans elles ne se
sentaient pas elle même quand elle était
par exemple en blouse blanche dans des
restaurants collective à cuisiner à la
chaîne des choucroutes des blanquette de
veau
alors c'est pas qu'elle n'aime pas les
blanquette de veau maintenant à la
cuisine comme personne en plus mais mais
dans ce rôle elle ne pouvait pas
exprimer leurs recettes leur tajine leur
tient pleurs coucou samedi sintas
iranien elle ne pouvait pas exprimer ses
recettes qu'elles se sont transmises de
génération en génération qui au final
font leur identité
un jour aïssata on a eu marre de ça elle
en a eu marre de cette aliénation
alors elle s'est lancée elle est venue
nous voir
et est ce qu'on lui a dit à ce moment-là
c'est bye sata reste toi même il fallait
pas lui dire deux fois et c'était
évident c'est tout ce qu'elle attendait
et au final c'est aussi tout ce que
attendait nos clients qui étaient lassés
de leur très tard habituel d'ailleurs je
me souviens d'une prestation où elle est
arrivée chez chanel plutôt à la dèche
les avec avec un habit traditionnel
merveilleux et surtout elle est arrivée
avec son plat le plus authentique
le poulet yassa il n'avait jamais vu ça
chez chanel mais ils ont adoré
ils ont adoré je crois qu'elle en a même
fait manger certains avec les mains
bref aysat avait réussi elle avait
réussit son but qui est de créer des
ponts entre les cultures pour que chacun
puisse exprimer sans se dénaturer rim
ne payez pas tout ce que je veux c'est
discuter avec des français c'est par ces
mots que rim nous a interpellés
aujourd'hui ils raisonnent encore en moi
parce qu'il signifie bien plus qu'il ne
suppose
rim avait sa place elle était mère de
quatre enfants elle était chef
d'entreprise elle vivait paisiblement
elle était rayonnante meriem a subi
toutes les pires atrocités qu'on puisse
imaginer pour une femme
imaginez vous faire réveiller par des
bombardements ou pire de voir drogué vos
enfants pourtant qu'ils n'entendent les
horreurs de la guerre
stop
c'en était trop en tout cas c'était
suffisant pour qu'avec sa famille fut le
pays
arrivée en france elle se devait pour
ses enfants de reconstruire une vie
normale de retrouver sa place mais au
final ces enfants n'ont pas eu
difficulté ils ont ils ont très vite
appris le français se sont fait des amis
ils se sont intégrés
mais pour elle ça a été un peu plus
compliquée en restant à la maison alors
ce cas-là compris c'était que pour
s'intégrer
elle devait faire un pas vers l'autre
elle devait s'intégrer vers l'autre
échanger partager communiqué rim à
perdre
chose en quittant son pays mais ce
qu'elle n'a pas perdu c'est l'humanité
dans son coeur alors elle fera tout ce
qu'il pourra pour faire un pas faire un
pas vers l'autre est ce pas là
c'est à travers la cuisine à travers ses
plats qu'elle cuisine toujours avec
amour
j'ai su qu'elle avait réussi quand lors
d'une prestation elle est arrivée voilée
devant un parterre de 200 banquiers en
costard cravate et au final c'était
merveilleux
tout le monde était à l'aise tout le
monde était heureux de partager est là
j'ai su j'ai su que rim avait trouvé sa
place sa place dans le coeur des
français
et moi dans tout cela
ma place c'est de permettre à d'autres
de trouver la leur cette construire des
projets tous plus fous les uns que les
autres et vous savez c'est quand que je
me sens le plus à l'aise c'est quand
avec dounia et du cev
on se regarde et on se dit mais qu'est
ce qu'on fout la terre je me suis dit en
rentrant je me dis mais qu'est ce que je
fous sur une fan de tedx mais j'adore ça
être en dehors de ma zone de confort il
est l'âme au confort j'adore par exemple
un jour j'ai débarqué avec toutes mes
mama à dauphine pour les former dans une
salle de classe ou bien on a fait parler
mama fouzia devant le ministre de
l'économie
ce que j'aime aussi c'est quand je passe
des heures avec une âme à discuter avec
elle elle est là ma place mais cette
place personne n'aurait pu me la donner
et encore moins me l'a dessinée je les
crée un monde d'image c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'invention de soi c'est ce que
je
encourage à faire aujourd'hui et
j'espère qu'avec ces cinq histoires vous
allez trouver un élément qui va vous
permettre de trouver votre place si les
mamans ont réussi vous pouvez aussi et
c'est important
c'est important pour vous mais ça c'est
important pour la société parce qu'au
final c'est comme ça que vous allez
avoir de l'impact
c'est comme ça que vous allez créer des
business de fou c'est comme ça que vous
allez vous sentir utile que vous allez
vous sentir vivre et au fond c'est un
peu tout ce qu'on recherche
alors laissez-vous être vous-même l'avez
vu il reste un dernier conseil d'
annuler team conserve la meilleure
classe n'est-elle pas parmi les gens
qu'on aime
on peut avoir la meilleure situation
possible la clé pour se sentir bien et
se sentir à sa place c'est d'être
entouré être entouré des gens qu'on aime
et qui nous aime être en sécurité parmi
les siens et sur ce coup là je suis
plutôt chanceuse puisque j'entreprends
un projet merveilleux avec une équipe
géniale des mamans formidable et avec ma
meilleure amie dounia et mon chéri mon
mari du chef
alors je profite de mes dernières
minutes sur seine pour leur dire merci
merci à vous de m'avoir taf de m'avoir
permis de trouver ma place
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]